Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. For every southern boy 14 years old, not once but whenever he wants it, there is the instant when it is still not yet two o'clock on that July afternoon in 1863. The brigades are in position behind the rail fence, the guns are laid and ready in the woods, and the furled flags were already loosened to break out. And Pickett himself, with his long oiled ringlets and his hat in one hand, probably, and his sword in the other, looking up the hill, waiting for Longstreet to give the word.
感谢收听《历史余温》。想要收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。对于每一个14岁的南方男孩来说，不仅是一次，而是每当他想起来的时候，总有那么一瞬间，时间仿佛停留在1863年7月那个下午两点之前。旅队在篱笆后就位，大炮在树林中架设完毕，卷起的旗帜已经松开，准备随时挥舞。皮克特本人留着油亮的长卷发，一只手可能拿着帽子，另一只手握着剑，抬头望着山坡，等待着朗斯特里特下达进攻的命令。
And it's all in the balance. It hasn't happened yet. It hasn't even begun yet. It not only hasn't begun yet, but there is still time for it not to begin against that position and those circumstances which made more men than garnet and kemper and armistead and wilcox look grave yet it's going to begin we all know that we've come too far with too much at stake and that moment doesn't need even a 14 year old boy to think this time maybe this time with all this much to lose than all this much to lose, then all this much to gain, Pennsylvania, Maryland, the world, the Golden Dome of Washington itself, to crown with desperate and unbelievable victory, the desperate gamble the cast made two years ago. That was William Faulkner, one of the great American novelists. William Faulkner? I thought it was a British author, Dominic. Well, it's too good. It's too good. The prose is too good for me to butcher
一切都悬而未决。事情还没有发生。甚至还没有开始。不仅还没有开始，而且还有时间阻止它在那种阵地和那种环境下发生，那种环境让加内特、肯珀、阿米斯特德和威尔科克斯等人都神情凝重。但它终究要开始了，我们都知道这一点，我们走得太远，赌注太大，那一刻甚至不需要一个14岁的男孩去思考：也许这一次，面对如此巨大的得失——宾夕法尼亚、马里兰、整个世界，甚至是华盛顿那金色的圆顶——去加冕那场孤注一掷、令人难以置信的胜利，那场两年前就已下注的豪赌。那是威廉·福克纳，美国最伟大的小说家之一。威廉·福克纳？我以为他是英国作家，多米尼克。好吧，这写得太好了。这散文写得太好了，我不能用我的美国口音去糟蹋它。
it with my American accent. So that's William Fultner, Intruders in the Dust, 1948. Not one of his best books, but probably his single most famous passage. And he's talking about the moment that generations of Southern boys looked back at and said, this was the high watermark of the Confederacy. The third day of the battle of Gettysburg, when it all went wrong for us. And Adam Smith, who's our guest professor, Adam Smith from the university of Oxford,
那是威廉·福克纳的《闯入尘土》，1948年出版。虽然不是他最好的书，但可能是他最著名的一段文字。他谈论的是几代南方男孩回首往事时所说的那个时刻，那是邦联的最高水位线。葛底斯堡战役的第三天，那是我们一切走向失败的时刻。亚当·史密斯，我们的客座教授，来自牛津大学的亚当·史密斯，
Adam, there's one moment that we'll get onto just in a second. Cause Tom is feeling bitter that his hero has not been, you know, the departure that he deserved but adam 1862 1863 in the midst of the american civil war can the confederacy still win do they think they're still going to win yes they definitely think they're still going to win and they can still win for the same reason that they could have won a year earlier which is by making the cost too high for the north to be prepared to pay yeah okay so if they've lost though one of their commanders um at the battle of chancellorsville
亚当，我们马上就要谈到一个时刻。因为汤姆对他的英雄没能得到应有的结局感到愤愤不平，但亚当，1862年、1863年，正值美国内战期间，邦联还能赢吗？他们认为自己还能赢吗？是的，他们绝对认为自己还能赢，而且他们确实还能赢，原因和一年前一样，那就是让北方付出他们无法承受的代价。是的，好吧，如果他们失去了一位指挥官，嗯，在钱瑟勒斯维尔战役中，
so they lose him in april when is it april 3rd, 1863. So this is Stonewall Jackson, and slightly embarrassingly for himself, he's shot by his own side, isn't he? By centuries. But not dead, but they take him away and then they saw off his arm and they bury his arm.
他们在四月失去了他，那是哪一天？1863年4月3日。那是石墙杰克逊，而且对他自己来说有点尴尬的是，他被自己人开枪打中了，不是吗？被哨兵。但他没死，但他们把他带走，然后锯掉了他的手臂，还把他的手臂埋了。
They bury his arm separately? Yeah. I think it then got dug up years later and they found it in a box. And reunited with the rest of him i think so yeah but but i mean even after that i mean just losing one commander doesn't lose you the war right but he's that good he's that good dominic that's what is it what's stonewall jackson's descendants got on you um robert e lee thinks yet again adam does he that he can launch an invasion of the north and basically break northern public opinion is that is that what he's thinking in this summer yeah and loads of other advantages too if he invades pennsylvania then he allows gives a bit of respite to virginia farmers
他们把他的手臂单独埋了？是的。我想后来过了几年又被挖了出来，他们在盒子里发现了它。我想是和他的身体其他部分重新合葬了。是的，但我的意思是，即使在那之后，失去一位指挥官并不会让你输掉战争，对吧？但他太出色了，他太出色了，多米尼克，石墙杰克逊的后代怎么看你？嗯，罗伯特·E·李再次认为，亚当，他可以发动对北方的入侵，并从根本上打破北方的舆论，这就是他那个夏天所想的吗？是的，还有很多其他优势。如果他入侵宾夕法尼亚，他就能让弗吉尼亚的农民得到一点喘息的机会，
maybe lets them get the harvest in he can do a bit of plundering it all kinds of advantages taking the war onto northern soil and And what's his ultimate target? His ultimate geographical target? Yeah. Well, he's a bit cagey about that, right? And actually, there's something that military historians have debated for generations, whether or not this invasion of Pennsylvania was a good idea. And those who criticize General Lee say that it was all a bit half-baked.
也许能让他们收割庄稼，他还可以进行一点掠夺，将战争带到北方领土上，这有各种各样的好处。那么他的最终目标是什么？他的地理目标是什么？嗯，他对此有点守口如瓶，对吧？事实上，这是军事历史学家争论了几代人的问题，即入侵宾夕法尼亚是否是一个好主意。那些批评李将军的人说，这完全是半生不熟的计划。
He really didn't get beyond the idea of wanting to go into Pennsylvania and win some big victory and he never really thought he threw much beyond that but yeah I mean it could have been Philadelphia maybe it could have even been as Falkner was kind of imagining in his sort of glittering nostalgic what it might have been imagination maybe it even could have been Washington, although the golden dome of the Capitol didn't actually exist at that time. It was still being constructed. That's disappointing. But Gettysburg in a way, I guess for people, it's the battle in the American civil war.
他确实没有超越想进入宾夕法尼亚并赢得一场大胜利的想法，他从未真正考虑过除此之外的更多东西。但是的，我的意思是，可能是费城，也许甚至可能是福克纳在他那种闪闪发光、怀旧的想象中可能想象的那样，也许甚至是华盛顿，尽管国会大厦那金色的圆顶在当时并不存在。它还在建设中。那真令人失望。但葛底斯堡在某种程度上，我想对人们来说，它是美国内战中的战役。
Yeah. And it's full of kind of romance and heroism and slaughter and horror and war is hell and war is glory, all kind of mixed up. Do you think it deserves that reputation? I do, actually. I mean, I should, you might not want to use this on the recording, but I have a kind of vested interest in it because I'm just finishing a book on Gettysburg and why Gettysburg is Gettysburg and why it's the battle of the war. Oh, no no we'll definitely keep that in i people really want to read that i really want to read that um but yes i do think gettysburg deserves that reputation because um it was it was three days of extraordinarily
是的。它充满了浪漫、英雄主义、屠杀、恐怖，战争是地狱，战争也是荣耀，所有这些都混杂在一起。你认为它配得上这种名声吗？我确实这么认为。我的意思是，我应该，你可能不想在录音中使用这个，但我对它有一种既得利益，因为我刚刚写完一本关于葛底斯堡的书，关于为什么葛底斯堡就是葛底斯堡，以及为什么它是那场战争的决定性战役。哦，不不，我们一定会保留这一段，人们真的很想读那本书，我真的很想读那本书。嗯，但是的，我确实认为葛底斯堡配得上那种名声，因为嗯，那是三天极其
bloody conflict by far the biggest battle on northern soil and it really was on northern soil it was on free soil it wasn't like antiet okay, in a state that hadn't seceded, but still a slave state, still a state that everyone regarded as southern. This was in the north. And if Lee's army had prevailed at Gettysburg, and they could have done, the political ramifications in the north would have been extraordinarily catastrophic for the Lincoln administration to lose a big battle after having lost all the previous battles, seemingly, that they'd fought against generally. But to lose a big battle after having lost all the previous battles, seemingly, that they'd fought against generally. But to lose this one on home soil would have been disastrous, disastrous for Lincoln. So I think the stakes were very high. People at the time thought they were, and I think they were right to think that.
血腥的冲突，是北方领土上规模最大的战役，而且它确实是在北方领土上，是在自由的土地上。它不像安提塔姆，好吧，是在一个没有脱离联邦的州，但仍然是一个蓄奴州，仍然是一个被所有人视为南方的地方。这是在北方。如果李的军队在葛底斯堡获胜，而且他们本可以获胜，那么北方的政治后果对林肯政府来说将是极其灾难性的，在输掉了之前所有似乎与李将军作战的战役之后，又输掉一场大仗。但在本土输掉这一场将是灾难性的，对林肯来说是灾难性的。所以我认为赌注非常高。当时的人们认为如此，我认为他们是对的。
I think there are a lot of reasons why Gettysburg is the battle that people remember, the battle of the Civil War. It sometimes feels like it's the whole war in microcosm. I think part of it, a lot of it, is this sense, and you captured this, that Faulkner quote that you've begun with, Dominic, captures this perfectly. That sense that Gettysburg was the moment when things could have gone differently. And after Gettysburg, time was running out for the Confederacy. So can we just give a very brief synopsis of what actually happens? Gettysburg, small town, supposedly famous for its shoes. Is that right? For its shoe shops?
我认为葛底斯堡之所以成为人们记忆中的那场内战战役，有很多原因。它有时感觉像是整个战争的缩影。我认为其中一部分，很大一部分，是这种感觉，你捕捉到了这一点，多米尼克，你开头引用的那段福克纳的话完美地捕捉到了这一点。那种感觉，葛底斯堡是事情可能走向不同方向的时刻。在葛底斯堡之后，邦联的时间不多了。那么我们能简要概述一下到底发生了什么吗？葛底斯堡，一个小镇，据说以鞋子闻名。那是真的吗？以鞋店闻名？
That's one of the many myths about Gettysburg is the notion that the Confederates went there to pick up some shoes. So that's not true, is it? This is not true. So the Northampton of the United States. South Central Pennsylvania. Yeah, is that right? The cobblers.
关于葛底斯堡的众多神话之一就是邦联去那里是为了买鞋。所以那不是真的，对吧？这不是真的。所以是美国的北安普顿。宾夕法尼亚州中南部。是的，是这样吗？鞋匠。
It's the Northampton town. No, that is total cobblers, actually, that theory. Yeah. No, the thing about Gettysburg is that it is at the centre of a spoke of roads. It's an important communication point. But it wasn't a place where either side intended to have a battle. It was what military historians call a meeting encounter. They just kind of basically bumped into each.
那是北安普顿镇。不，那个理论完全是胡扯。是的。不，葛底斯堡的特点是它位于道路的中心。它是一个重要的交通枢纽。但它并不是双方打算进行战斗的地方。这就是军事历史学家所说的遭遇战。他们基本上就是撞上了对方。
The armies bumped into each other there. All the descriptions say they collided. But, I mean, they must have known where they were going. Well, they sort of, I mean, they knew where they were going and they knew where they were, but what they didn't know was where the enemy was. Jeb Stuart, who is the kind of the great cavalry commander, now that Stonewall Jackson's dead, isn't he kind of, he's off rounding up wagons or something? Well, he's, your man Stonewall was not the cavalry commander commander so his big loss the big loss for lee is that he doesn't have his right hand man helping him sort of intuitively understanding what lee's
军队在那里撞上了对方。所有的描述都说他们发生了碰撞。但是，我的意思是，他们一定知道他们要去哪里。嗯，他们某种程度上，我的意思是，他们知道他们要去哪里，也知道他们在哪里，但他们不知道的是敌人在哪里。杰布·斯图尔特，那位伟大的骑兵指挥官，现在石墙杰克逊死了，他不是那种，他去围捕马车什么的了吗？嗯，他是，你说的石墙不是骑兵指挥官，所以他损失惨重，李的重大损失在于他没有得力助手在现场直觉地理解李想要做什么，
wanted wanting to do on the field by the time they come to gettysburg instead he's got general longstreet who lee is not let's just say not quite as in tune with as he was with uh stonewall um but jeb stewart um what what jeb stewart is doing is going off on a massive raid, which Lee had kind of told him to do. But Lee has this way of giving orders, which gives a great deal of discretion to all his officers. Because that's very Prince Rupert, isn't it? Dashing off and not sticking around to help with the battle. Very cavalier. And so the fact that Jeb Stuart wasn't maintaining regular, the function of the cavalry is mainly an intelligence operation. Their function is to tell the commander where the enemy troops are.
当他们来到葛底斯堡时，他有朗斯特里特将军，李与他的默契程度不如与石墙杰克逊那样高。但杰布·斯图尔特，杰布·斯图尔特正在进行大规模突袭，这是李让他做的。但李有一种下达命令的方式，给予他所有军官很大的自由裁量权。因为那非常像鲁珀特亲王，不是吗？冲出去，而不是留下来帮助战斗。非常傲慢。所以杰布·斯图尔特没有保持常规，骑兵的功能主要是情报行动。他们的职责是告诉指挥官敌军在哪里。
And Jeb Stuart was out of contact with General Lee for a crucial period of days. And that was a massive problem for Lee. So Lee, you know, to answer Dominic's question, Lee didn't know where the Union Army was. And the Union Army had better intelligence about Lee, but not brilliant intelligence either. And so the commander of the Union is a new general, George Meade. And the only thing I really know about him is that he had a horse called Baldy, which is a great name for a horse. And he turns up with his guys. And one of the things that makes Gettysburg interesting for military historians, and I think for visitors, is that Gettysburg is surrounded by a large number of hills, isn't it?
而杰布·斯图尔特在关键的几天里与李将军失去了联系。这对李来说是一个巨大的问题。所以李，你知道，回答多米尼克的问题，李不知道联邦军队在哪里。而联邦军队对李有更好的情报，但也不是非常出色。所以联邦的指挥官是一位新将军，乔治·米德。我对他真正了解的唯一一件事是他有一匹叫“秃头”的马，这对马来说是个好名字。他带着他的人出现了。葛底斯堡让军事历史学家，我想也让游客感兴趣的一点是，葛底斯堡被许多山丘环绕，不是吗？
And the problem with battlefields is if you don't have distinctive terrain, so you can't work out what's going on. But with Gettysburg, it's who controls the heights that becomes the key. Is that right? Yes. So do you want me to give you a kind of capsule description of the battle of gettysburg three days we'd love that adam then i'll give it a go so it's very conveniently it's fought over the first second and third of july so when the union to spoiler alert
战场的问题在于，如果你没有独特的地形，你就无法弄清楚发生了什么。但对于葛底斯堡来说，谁控制了高地就成了关键。是这样吗？是的。那么你想让我给你一个关于葛底斯堡战役的简要描述吗？三天，我们很乐意，亚当。那我就试一试。所以非常方便的是，它发生在7月1日、2日和3日，所以当联邦——剧透预警——
the union wins this battle and so they're able to celebrate it on the fourth of july which is great for them three day battle first three days of the month. The first day is essentially a Confederate victory that follows the pattern of lots of previous battles. So the Union Army make a lot of stupid errors. And by the end of the day, the Confederate Army is in control of the town of Gettysburg but but the union army have retreated onto high ground on cemetery hill which is just i mean if you go there today it's like a 20 minute walk out of the town center and apparently there was a sign saying you weren't allowed to bear firearms in the cemetery so that was that was the first day um The second day, what happens is that the Confederates then spread out along a line running kind of parallel to the Union line. So the Union lines begin anchored in Cemetery Hill, just outside of the town of Gettysburg, just to the south of the town, and then running for about a mile in a kind of southerly to southeasterly
联邦赢得了这场战役，所以他们能够在7月4日庆祝，这对他们来说太棒了。为期三天的战役，本月的前三天。第一天基本上是邦联的胜利，遵循了许多先前战役的模式。所以联邦军队犯了很多愚蠢的错误。到那天结束时，邦联军队控制了葛底斯堡镇，但联邦军队撤退到了公墓山的高地上，这只是，我的意思是，如果你今天去那里，从市中心走过去只要20分钟，而且显然有一个标志说你不允许在公墓携带枪支，所以那是第一天。嗯，第二天，发生的事情是邦联军队沿着一条与联邦防线平行的线散开。所以联邦防线开始锚定在公墓山，就在葛底斯堡镇外，就在镇的南面，然后延伸了大约一英里，呈一种从南到东南的方向，
direction along a ridge known as Cemetery Ridge. The Confederates are kind of parallel to them, about a mile away along another ridge of land called Seminary Ridge. So they're sort of facing each other. And Adam, to give people a sense of the numbers, these are now absolutely enormous armies. So the Union have what about 100 000 men yeah the confederates about 75 000 or something yeah yeah so these are these much much bigger armies than they were at the beginning of the war now yes so it's rather like the first world war they've just swelled and swelled and swelled as time has gone on yes yes and then with all of the horses and all of the wagons that go behind it and the African-Americans who are impressed by the Confederate Army to
沿着一条被称为公墓岭的山脊。邦联军队与他们平行，大约一英里外，沿着另一条被称为神学院岭的山脊。所以他们某种程度上是面对面的。亚当，为了让人们对人数有个概念，这些现在是绝对庞大的军队。所以联邦有大约10万人，是的，邦联大约75,000人左右，是的，是的，所以这些军队比战争开始时大得多，现在是的，所以这有点像第一次世界大战，随着时间的推移，他们不断膨胀，膨胀，再膨胀，是的，是的，还有所有的马匹和所有的马车，以及被邦联军队强征的非裔美国人，
dig ditches and latrines and put up tents and things behind the line. So there's a big operation as well as the enlisted men. Yeah. So these are two big cities moving around with horses and wagons clanking across the South Central Pennsylvania landscape. You can stand on the top of Cemetery Ridge today where the Union lines were and look towards the west and you see a line of blue hills in the distance and the fields sloping away from you and then up again towards a line of trees
去挖掘沟渠和厕所，在防线后面搭帐篷之类的。所以除了应征入伍的士兵外，还有一个庞大的行动。是的。所以这是两座巨大的城市，带着马匹和马车在宾夕法尼亚州中南部的景观中穿行。你今天可以站在联邦防线所在的公墓岭顶上，向西望去，你会看到远处有一排蓝色的山丘，田野从你身边倾斜而下，然后又向上延伸到一排树木，
about a mile away in the distance. And that's where the Confederate line was formed. So the second day of the battle essentially consisted of attempts by the Confederates to break through the Union line. Confederate line was formed. So the second day of the battle essentially consisted of attempts by the Confederates to break through the Union line. If they could have done that, if they could have encircled, or if they could have flanked the Union army, then they could have got between the Union army and Washington, or between the Union army and Philadelphia. And that would have obviously been a very dangerous situation for the Union. And so the second day consisted of a series of essentially failed efforts by the Confederacy to break through. But they had significant successes and the Union army made some more errors. And so going into the third day, General Lee, who wants to win, and all his instincts are that he always wins. That's what his army does. And so going into the third day, General Lee thinks one last push.
大约一英里外。那就是邦联防线形成的地方。所以战役的第二天基本上包括了邦联试图突破联邦防线的尝试。邦联防线形成的地方。所以战役的第二天基本上包括了邦联试图突破联邦防线的尝试。如果他们能做到这一点，如果他们能包围，或者如果他们能侧翼包抄联邦军队，那么他们就能进入联邦军队和华盛顿之间，或者联邦军队和费城之间。那显然对联邦来说是一个非常危险的情况。所以第二天包括了一系列基本上失败的邦联突破努力。但他们取得了重大成功，联邦军队又犯了一些错误。所以进入第三天，想要获胜的李将军，他所有的本能都是他总是获胜。这就是他的军队所做的。所以进入第三天，李将军认为最后再推一把。
If we focus, if he focuses all his forces on one point and he can identify a point, a little clump of trees that's become known as a copse, a copse of trees, which is not really a word that's generally used in American English, but a copse of trees that's a visible marker on Cemetery Ridge. He focuses all of his forces on that one point, and then he can blast through. That's his idea. Doesn't work, but it could have done. And why does it not work? Tell us what happens. So what happens on July the 3rd is that they, at around about lunchtime, I mean, the times of all this are hotly debated.
如果他集中所有兵力于一点，并且他能确定一个点，一小片树林，被称为“树丛”，这不是美国英语中常用的词，但那片树林是公墓岭上的一个可见标记。他将所有兵力集中在那一点，然后他就能炸开缺口。这就是他的想法。没成功，但本可以成功。为什么没成功？告诉我们发生了什么。所以7月3日发生的事情是，大约在午餐时间，我的意思是，所有这些的时间都备受争议。
It's amazing. You read military historians and they often write with a kind of air of extraordinary confidence about what's happening down to the minute. In fact, all of the timings of this and the numbers of people involved are all under dispute. But round about lunchtime, let's say, an hour and a half to two hour long artillery bombardment begins with the aim of knocking out the Union artillery. So that's very First World War. It's very First World War. It's very First World War. And the Union artillery falls silent, doesn't it? The Union artillery does fall silent for a while.
这太神奇了。你读军事历史学家的书，他们写的时候往往带着一种非凡的自信，精确到分钟。事实上，所有这些的时间安排和参与人数都存在争议。但大约在午餐时间，我们说，一个半到两个小时的炮击开始了，目的是摧毁联邦的炮兵。所以这非常像第一次世界大战。这非常像第一次世界大战。这非常像第一次世界大战。联邦炮兵沉默了，不是吗？联邦炮兵确实沉默了一会儿。
And in part, that's deliberate to lull the Confeder a into a false sense that they've overachieved in fact a lot of the the confederate shells are overshooting their mark um but nevertheless the noise uh and the devastation caused by this artillery bombardment is massive. And the smoke, of course, that fills then the space in between the lines. And then we get to that moment that Faulkner fantasized about, or that Faulkner imagined every 14-year-old Southern boy, and as late as the 1940s, fantasizing about, when the decision has to be made. But the decision really has already been taken, right? You've done this artillery bombardment, then the troops have to step off and becomes known as pickett's charge because general pickett who really does fit into the mold of a cavalier more so with the ringlets and everything yes he's very he's very much got
在某种程度上，这是故意的，为了让邦联陷入一种他们已经超额完成任务的错觉，事实上，许多邦联炮弹都打过了头。嗯，但尽管如此，这种炮击造成的噪音和破坏是巨大的。当然，还有烟雾，填满了防线之间的空间。然后我们到了福克纳幻想的那一刻，或者福克纳想象每个14岁的南方男孩，甚至直到1940年代，都在幻想的那一刻，当必须做出决定时。但决定其实已经做出了，对吧？你进行了这次炮击，然后部队必须出发，这就是所谓的皮克特冲锋，因为皮克特将军，他确实更符合骑士的形象，留着卷发等等，是的，他非常，他非常有
the ringlets hasn't he pickett is the guy who's most associated with this assault in fact it's not just pickett's division. But I mean, for the sake of this discussion, we can still carry on calling it Pickett's Charge because it's too confusing not to. So the Confederates advance across this mile of land. There's a lot of smoke. There are picket fences in the way. There's a road that they have to maneuver across.
卷发，不是吗？皮克特是与这次突击联系最紧密的人，事实上，不仅仅是皮克特的师。但我的意思是，为了这次讨论，我们可以继续称之为皮克特冲锋，因为如果不这样称呼太令人困惑了。所以邦联军队穿过这一英里的土地。有很多烟雾。路上有栅栏。有一条路他们必须穿过。
At various points, they become invisible to Union troops because of the undulations of the land or because smoke obscures them. But as they come closer, as they start walking up the hill in close formation up Cemetery Ridge towards the Union lines, the Union defenders open fire. They first of all open fire with shrapnel, artillery pieces blast out at the advancing Confederate lines, and then with rifles. And in the end, as small bunches of Confederates come close up to the stone wall, where at the angle of the union line,
在某些点，由于地形的起伏或烟雾的遮挡，他们变得对联邦军队不可见。但当他们靠近时，当他们开始以紧密队形爬上山坡，向公墓岭上的联邦防线走去时，联邦守军开火了。他们首先用榴霰弹开火，炮兵向推进的邦联防线开火，然后用步枪。最后，当一小群邦联士兵靠近石墙时，在联邦防线的拐角处，
just in front of this copse of trees at the center of all of this action, small bunches of Confederates do in fact break through and this fierce bayonet fighting. But they don't have anything like the numbers to be able to hold that position. in the end they're forced they're forced back um and in a bedraggled um bloodied ness um limp the survivors limp back up the hill to seminary ridge where reportedly uh robert e lee is standing and telling them all that it's it's his fault it's his fault doesn't he he says that and then pick it years later kind of says you destroyed my men but that moment adam when they get to the angle because the angle is like a sort of stone wall a stone fence or something isn't it yeah that moment that's historically been seen as the high watermark of the confederacy so i mean i mean is it is that fair i mean is that the closest they ever came to victory when those few men broke through to that
就在所有这些行动中心的树丛前面，一小群邦联士兵确实突破了，并进行了激烈的白刃战。但他们没有足够的人数来守住那个阵地。最后，他们被迫撤退，嗯，在衣衫褴褛、血迹斑斑的狼狈中，幸存者一瘸一拐地回到神学院岭，据报道，罗伯特·E·李站在那里，告诉他们这一切都是他的错，都是他的错，不是吗？他说了那句话，然后皮克特多年后说，你摧毁了我的部下。但那个时刻，亚当，当他们到达拐角处时，因为拐角处就像某种石墙或石栅栏，不是吗？是的，那个时刻在历史上一直被视为邦联的最高水位线。所以我的意思是，这公平吗？我的意思是，那是他们最接近胜利的时刻吗，当那几个人突破到那个
fence well if that puncturing of the union line on July 3rd had been successful, and somehow they'd been able to turn and the Union army had panicked and run, which is what General Lee hoped for. And therefore, if the Battle of Gettysburg had turned the other way, then that would have been a massive strategic success for the Confederacyacy um as it was that defeat on the july the third and the fact that lee's army was then forced to retreat a day later back into virginia broke the myth of invincibility of the army of northern virginia of lee's army Lee's Army was never again in a position to be able to invade the North. It was never again as strong as it was. It never again had this sense of destiny on its side as it had done in that moment. It very nearly got wiped out, didn't it? It very
栅栏时？嗯，如果7月3日对联邦防线的穿透成功了，并且他们以某种方式能够转向，而联邦军队惊慌失措并逃跑，这正是李将军所希望的。因此，如果葛底斯堡战役的结果反过来，那么这对邦联来说将是一个巨大的战略成功。嗯，事实是，7月3日的失败，以及李的军队在一天后被迫撤回弗吉尼亚的事实，打破了北弗吉尼亚军团、李的军队不可战胜的神话。李的军队再也没有能力入侵北方。它再也没有像以前那样强大。它再也没有像那一刻那样拥有命运在握的感觉。它差点被消灭，不是吗？它非常
nearly got wiped out. I mean, Lincoln gets furious with Meade for not chasing him. Following up afterwards and not stopping General Lee's Army, recrossing the army of the Potomac and getting back into Virginia, especially since it started raining the next day. And so the river was in flood. And so it was really touch and go whether the army of Northern Virginia would be able to get back across the river. So again, I mean, it's another what if, you know, on July the 3rd, maybe the Union could have lost. And on July 4th, maybe the Confederacy could have been wrapped up in a single day but maybe all these what-ifs they they slightly miss the point that it's that classic example of the underdog and the overdog in a war where the underdog can win 20 battles but as soon as the overdog wins one the underdog is up against
差点被消灭。我的意思是，林肯对米德没有追击他感到愤怒。事后没有跟进，没有阻止李将军的军队重新跨过波托马克河回到弗吉尼亚，尤其是第二天开始下雨。所以河水泛滥。所以北弗吉尼亚军团能否回到河对岸真的是悬而未决。所以，我的意思是，这是另一个“如果”，你知道，在7月3日，也许联邦可能会输。而在7月4日，也许邦联可能会在一天之内被解决。但也许所有这些“如果”都稍微偏离了重点，这是战争中弱者和强者之间的一个经典例子，弱者可以赢得20场战役，但只要强者赢得一场，弱者就陷入了困境，
it because of lack of resources lack of manpower andpower. And that's the importance of Gettysburg, isn't it? That the Confederacy basically can't afford to lose one massive battle like this. But Dominic, isn't it also, I mean, so the romance of Pickett's Charge, and it's been framed in the Faulkner passage that you opened with, that this is the moment where perhaps it could all have changed and been different and the Confederacy could have held out. But what it also reminds me of, and I don't know whether this is the moment where perhaps it could all have changed and been different and the Confederacy could have held out. But what it also reminds me of, and I don't know whether this is a conventional comparison, is with something that had happened
因为缺乏资源，缺乏人力。这就是葛底斯堡的重要性，不是吗？邦联基本上输不起这样一场大规模的战役。但多米尼克，难道不是吗？我的意思是，皮克特冲锋的浪漫色彩，以及你开头引用的福克纳段落中构建的框架，即这是事情可能发生改变、变得不同、邦联可能坚持下去的时刻。但它也让我想起，我不知道这是否是事情可能发生改变、变得不同、邦联可能坚持下去的时刻。但它也让我想起，我不知道这是否是一个传统的比较，八年前发生的事情，
eight years previously, which is the Charge of the Light Brigade. And the whole point of the Charge of the Light Brigade is precisely that it is doomed. You know, it's an insane thing to do, to kind of charge across an open field artillery that are going to play you out is that a far-fetched comparison or is it the fact that it is precisely such an insane thing to do that has made it kind of live on so enduringly it's it's the kind of lunatic courage of it that has given it this kind of aura of romance that is what's given it an aura of romance but i don't think it's actually true i don't think it's comparable to the charge of the light brigade in terms of it as a kind of lunatic um tactic i
那就是轻骑兵冲锋。而轻骑兵冲锋的全部意义恰恰在于它是注定失败的。你知道，这是一种疯狂的行为，冲过开阔地带去面对炮火，这是否是一个牵强的比较，还是说正是因为这种疯狂的行为，才让它如此持久地流传下来？这是一种疯狂的勇气，赋予了它这种浪漫的光环，这就是赋予它浪漫光环的原因，但我认为这其实不是真的，我不认为它在作为一种疯狂战术方面可以与轻骑兵冲锋相提并论，我
think it could have worked i mean the odds were against it but i think given given where lee was on the morning of july the third i can understand why he thought this was a viable option. I can also understand, and obviously as events proved, he was proved to be correct, but I can also understand why General Longstreet, who'd stepped into Stonewall Jackson's place as Lee's number two, warned Lee against it and said that he couldn't imagine any group of men, even Lee's men, being able to take a position so well defended. But the thing was, Lee had taken a major.
认为它本可以成功，我的意思是，胜算不大，但我认为考虑到李在7月3日早晨所处的位置，我可以理解为什么他认为这是一个可行的选择。我也能理解，显然正如事件所证明的那样，他被证明是正确的，但我也能理解为什么朗斯特里特将军，他接替了石墙杰克逊成为李的二把手，警告李不要这样做，并说他无法想象任何一群人，即使是李的部下，能够攻下一个防御如此严密的阵地。但问题是，李曾取得过重大胜利。
He had done daring things in the past. As recently as just two months earlier, he'd won this extraordinary battle in Chancellorsville in Virginia where he'd been outnumbered two to one and he'd divided his army twice in the face of overwhelming numbers. And yet he got away with it. So he was lucky. He was a lucky general. And that's what his men thought about him.
他在过去做过大胆的事情。就在两个月前，他在弗吉尼亚赢得了那场非凡的钱瑟勒斯维尔战役，当时他以一敌二，并且在面对压倒性数量的敌人时两次分兵。然而他成功了。所以他很幸运。他是一位幸运的将军。这就是他的部下对他的看法。
Until Nemesis came calling. And Adam, the other thing that happens on the 4th of July, as well as the retreat from Gettysburg, is on the Mississippi, where the great fortress of Vicksburg that has been besieged by another Union General, Ulysses S. Grant, falls. How key is that? Well, that's really key. And it's the two of them together, the repulse of Lear Gettysburg and the fall of Vicksburg that together seem to set the seal on the Confederacy. So then the interesting question is, why did the war go on for another two years? Because of the fall of Vicksburg, Confederacy is cut in two. The Mississippi River is completely in Union hands. Texas is now this kind of far-flclement of Virginia, which takes place as General Sherman then marches his men through to Atlanta and eventually to the sea and the scorched earth policy and all this after the break. But a last note about Gettysburg, because obviously this isn't the last of Gettysburg in the story, because months later, on the 19th of November 1863, Abraham Lincoln returns. Well, he comes to Gettysburg. I think people often think that the two things are kind of simultaneous, don't they?
直到复仇女神来敲门。亚当，7月4日发生的另一件事，除了从葛底斯堡撤退外，是在密西西比河，被另一位联邦将军尤利西斯·S·格兰特围困的维克斯堡大要塞陷落了。这有多关键？嗯，这真的很关键。这两者结合在一起，李在葛底斯堡的被击退和维克斯堡的陷落，似乎共同为邦联盖棺定论。那么有趣的问题是，为什么战争又持续了两年？因为维克斯堡的陷落，邦联被一分为二。密西西比河完全掌握在联邦手中。德克萨斯现在是弗吉尼亚的一个遥远部分，这发生在谢尔曼将军随后带领他的部下穿过亚特兰大，最终到达大海，以及焦土政策，所有这些都在休息之后。但关于葛底斯堡的最后一点，因为显然这不是故事中葛底斯堡的最后一次，因为几个月后，1863年11月19日，亚伯拉罕·林肯回来了。嗯，他来到了葛底斯堡。我想人们通常认为这两件事是同时发生的，不是吗？
They sort of assume he pitched up the day after the battle to give the Gettysburg Address. But this is, he's inaugurating a cemetery and he gives this speech, which is probably the single most famous speech of the entire American Civil War. It's only 272 words. Why is it so well known, Adam? What's so important about it? Because he distills the reasons for which the North is fighting. He answers your question, Dominic, from the last episode, which is why are the North bothering to fight this war? That's what he does in those 272 words. And he does it significantly on the battlefield, which everybody already by then thinks is the most important battlefield of the war. And he does it, as you say, opening a cemetery to the
他们假设他在战役结束后第二天就赶去发表葛底斯堡演说。但这是，他是在为公墓揭幕，他发表了这篇演讲，这可能是整个美国内战中最著名的演讲。只有272个字。为什么它如此出名，亚当？它有什么重要之处？因为它提炼了北方战斗的原因。他回答了你多米尼克在上集提出的问题，即北方为什么要费心打这场战争？这就是他在那272个字中所做的。而且他是在战场上完成的，每个人到那时都已经认为这是战争中最重要的战场。而且正如你所说，他是在为
Union dead. And of course, they can't do this on most Civil War battlefields, because most Civil War battlefields are still in contested ground in Virginia, but he can go to Gettysburg. And so he can turn Gettysburg into this sacred place where even in advance of Union victory, he can explain what this struggle is all about. And can I just ask, I mean, this is something quite new, isn't it? This idea of commemorating the dead, of setting up cemeteries. I mean, because obviously it's something that becomes massive in the First World War and the Second World War and so on in the rest of the world. But this is, I mean, it's, is there an echo here of Pericles in the Peloponnesian war giving a funeral oration over the Athenian dead, which is a kind of, you know, a masterpiece of political oratory? Is that a kind of conscious influence?
联邦阵亡将士揭幕公墓时做的。当然，他们不能在大多数内战战场上这样做，因为大多数内战战场仍然是弗吉尼亚的争议地区，但他可以去葛底斯堡。所以他可以把葛底斯堡变成这个神圣的地方，即使在联邦胜利之前，他也可以解释这场斗争的意义所在。我能问一下吗，我的意思是，这相当新，不是吗？这种纪念死者、建立公墓的想法。我的意思是，因为显然这在第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战等世界其他地方变得非常普遍。但这是，我的意思是，这里是否有伯里克利在伯罗奔尼撒战争中为雅典死者发表葬礼演说的回声，那是一种，你知道，政治演说的杰作？这是一种有意识的影响吗？
It was a conscious influence on the main speaker on that occasion, Edward Everett, who spoke for two hours without any notes and regarded himself as the Pericles of the 1860s. Lincoln was familiar enough as you had to be in the mid-Victorian period with classical references to have heard of Pericles, but I think there was certainly no direct influence on Lincoln's speech. But also the idea of a democracy, because that's what the Gettysburg is addressed, the idea that democracy in and of itself has value, that is obviously something that can be drawn from the Athenian example. And I guess conversely, for the Confederacy, also Athens is quite an important kind of model, it's it's it's a democracy but it's it's a slave-owning democracy yes yes yes yes that's right and that comparison was made at the time um very directly um and and
这对那次活动的主要发言人爱德华·埃弗雷特来说是一个有意识的影响，他没有带任何笔记讲了两个小时，并认为自己是1860年代的伯里克利。林肯像维多利亚时代中期的人一样熟悉古典参考资料，足以听说过伯里克利，但我认为对林肯的演讲肯定没有直接影响。但还有民主的想法，因为这就是葛底斯堡演说的内容，民主本身就有价值的想法，这显然是可以从雅典的例子中汲取的。我想反过来说，对于邦联，雅典也是一个相当重要的模式，它是一个民主国家，但它是一个蓄奴的民主国家，是的，是的，是的，是的，那是对的，那个比较在当时被非常直接地提了出来，而且
has been made uh many times since um i mean you're right about the importance of the the manner of commemoration of the dead with the uniform headstones of the kind that we're very familiar with from thinking about first world war cemeteries i mean the the dead at touton or of the dead with the uniform headstones of the kind that we're very familiar with from thinking about First World War cemeteries. I mean, the dead at Towton or even the dead at Waterloo, the bones were ploughed into the ground. And at Gettysburg, they were laid out in serried ranks. And they're not wearing kind of dog tags or anything like that? Are they?
自那以后被提过很多次，我的意思是，你关于纪念死者方式的重要性是对的，那种我们从思考第一次世界大战公墓中非常熟悉的统一墓碑。我的意思是，陶顿的死者，或者甚至滑铁卢的死者，骨头都被犁进了地里。而在葛底斯堡，他们被整齐地排列着。他们没有戴那种身份牌之类的东西，是吗？
No, and so there's a huge difficulty over the identification of remains. And there's a whole long and pretty grim story about the process of disinterring bodies that had been laid in shallow graves in the days immediately after the battle. And the impossibility in many cases of identifying those remains. But enough of them are identified, or they think they are identified sufficiently to be able to inter them in this new cemetery, where in terms of the form of the gravestones, the officers and the men are equal in death. And it is a very moving speech. I mean, we hear highly resolved that these dead shall not have died in vain, that this nation under God shall have a new birth of freedom and the government of the people, by the people, for the people
没有，所以遗骸的鉴定有巨大的困难。关于在战役结束后几天内被埋在浅坟中的尸体的挖掘过程，有一个漫长而相当残酷的故事。在许多情况下，鉴定这些遗骸是不可能的。但其中足够多的人被鉴定出来，或者他们认为他们被充分鉴定出来，能够将他们安葬在这个新的公墓中，在墓碑的形式上，军官和士兵在死亡面前是平等的。这是一个非常感人的演讲。我的意思是，我们听到“下定决心，这些死者不会白白牺牲，这个国家在上帝的保佑下将获得自由的新生，民有、民治、民享的政府
shall not perish from the earth. I mean, he doesn't do it in my beautiful Laurence Olivier style. Daniel Day-Lewis. Because doesn't he have quite a reedy voice, Lincoln? Is that right? Yes, he was supposed to have had quite a high-pitched voice, but it was a carrying voice, a voice that people could nevertheless hear. Well, we've just, just very quickly, there's a question from Henri de Toulouse-Lautrec, which despite his name, seems to be American. And he asked, Tom, how well known is the Gettysburg Address internationally? It's known by most Americans and taught in schools as the pinnacle of both American political thought, as well as writing poetry and rhetoric. It makes me cry every time I hear it. I mean, I would say it is pretty well known outside America. I mean, obviously not as well known as in America, but it's certainly fated as one of
将不会从地球上消失”。我的意思是，他没有用我美丽的劳伦斯·奥利弗风格来做。丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯。因为林肯的声音不是相当尖细吗？是这样吗？是的，他被认为声音相当高，但那是一种有穿透力的声音，人们仍然可以听到的声音。好吧，我们刚刚，非常快地，有一个来自亨利·德·图卢兹-劳特雷克的提问，尽管他的名字，似乎是美国人。他问，汤姆，葛底斯堡演说在国际上有多出名？大多数美国人都知道，并在学校里作为美国政治思想以及诗歌和修辞的巅峰来教授。每次听到它我都会流泪。我的意思是，我会说它在美国以外也相当出名。我的意思是，显然不如在美国那么出名，但它肯定被誉为
the great speeches of all time, I would say. Oh, unquestionably. Have you, you know, Mrs. Sancho recorded the Gettysburg Address. Did you know that? I did not know that. I should have read it in my excellent listen i think we've dodged a bullet here um dominic is gearing up to read the gettysburg address in the voice of mrs thatcher i i think we should take a break at this point um you hear highly resolved no dominic dominic not have died in vain mr scargill and his confederate we're going to take a break here and when we come back I think we should look at the black experience
有史以来最伟大的演讲之一，我会说。哦，毫无疑问。你，你知道，桑乔夫人录制了葛底斯堡演说。你知道吗？我不知道。我应该用我出色的声音读出来，听着，我想我们在这里躲过了一劫，嗯，多米尼克正准备用撒切尔夫人的声音朗读葛底斯堡演说，我想我们应该在这一点上休息一下，你听到“下定决心”，不，多米尼克，多米尼克，不要白白牺牲，斯卡吉尔先生和他的邦联，我们在这里休息一下，当我们回来时，我想我们应该看看黑人的经历
in the civil war and the end of the war so we'll be back after the break I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
在内战中以及战争的结束，所以休息后我们会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐余温》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，
if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're joined by Margaret Thatcher for this cruelly denied you performance of the Gettysburg Address in the previous half. But anyway, so Adam Smith from Oxford University. I'm sure at Oxford they don't do impersonations of Margaret Thatcher reading the Gettysburg Address, do they? Well, I do in my lectures, but I'm not sure anyone else has ever done it
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》。玛格丽特·撒切尔加入了我们，弥补了上一半中被残酷拒绝的葛底斯堡演说表演。但无论如何，牛津大学的亚当·史密斯。我相信在牛津，他们不会模仿玛格丽特·撒切尔朗读葛底斯堡演说，对吧？嗯，我在讲座中会这样做，但我不知道还有没有其他人这样做过。
in the history of the university before. No, I imagine not. All right, listen, there's a group of people we haven't really talked about at all, extraordinarily, and they're the people at the centre of the drama, really. They're the people the drama is all about. So they are black Americans. And I suppose there are, I mean there are you know it's a hugely
在大学的历史上之前。不，我想没有。好吧，听着，有一群人我们几乎完全没有提到，这很不可思议，他们实际上是这场戏剧的核心人物。他们是这场戏剧所围绕的人。他们就是美国黑人。我想，我的意思是，你知道这是一个非常
variegated story but let's talk about two particular groups adam one is black soldiers who fight for the union because anyone who's seen the film glory will know that this is at once a contentious but also a very inspiring story and then the second group i think it's worth us talking about is actually the people who who really who the war is about, who are the slaves, the enslaved people in the Confederacy. So do the Union have black soldiers right from the beginning? No, that's right, isn't it? No, they don't. One of the things the Emancipation Proclamation does is to pave the way for the enlistment of black troops. And in the end, I think 186,000 black men enlist in the Union Army, and another 15,000 or 20,000 in the Union Navy. And so make a hugely important contribution to
多样化的故事，但让我们谈谈两个特定的群体，亚当。一个是为联邦而战的黑人士兵，因为任何看过电影《光荣战役》的人都会知道，这既是一个有争议的，也是一个非常鼓舞人心的故事。然后第二个群体，我认为值得我们讨论的，实际上是这场战争真正关乎的人，也就是奴隶，邦联中的被奴役者。那么联邦从一开始就有黑人士兵吗？不，那是对的，不是吗？不，他们没有。《解放黑人奴隶宣言》所做的事情之一就是为黑人部队的征募铺平了道路。最终，我认为有18万6千名黑人加入了联邦军队，还有1万5千到2万名加入了联邦海军。因此，他们做出了极其重要的贡献，
Union victory in numbers terms alone, in addition to the ideological and political importance of their service. But they're fighting in segregated units. They're not allowed to mix. They're earning less pay, aren't they? They are earning less pay throughout almost the whole of the war. They're fighting in segregated units and mostly officered by white men, often abolitionists. And a huge issue, what happens to them if they get captured?
仅从人数上来看，联邦的胜利，此外还有他们服役的意识形态和政治重要性。但他们是在种族隔离的部队中作战。他们不被允许混编。他们的薪水更低，不是吗？他们在整个战争期间几乎一直拿着更低的薪水。他们是在种族隔离的部队中作战，军官大多是白人，通常是废奴主义者。还有一个巨大的问题，如果他们被俘虏了会怎样？
I mean, this is a huge issue because, of course, arming black men is the ultimate nightmare in a slave society. And so the Emancipation Proclamation is incredibly threatening to the Confederacy, but the enlistment of black troops is the ultimate insult. In fact, it's more than just an insult. It threatens to blow apart their whole theory, the whole theory on which slavery is based, which is that black men are incapable. And so the Confederacy refused to treat black soldiers as they would treat white soldiers. And they're treating white soldiers pretty badly, right?
我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题，因为当然，武装黑人在奴隶社会中是终极噩梦。因此，《解放黑人奴隶宣言》对邦联来说极具威胁性，而征募黑人部队则是终极侮辱。事实上，这不仅仅是侮辱。它威胁要粉碎他们的整个理论，即奴隶制所基于的全部理论，那就是黑人是无能的。因此，邦联拒绝像对待白人士兵那样对待黑人士兵。而他们对待白人士兵也相当糟糕，对吧？
I mean, they're kind of locking them up in concentration camps and starving them and so on. They're putting them in prisoner of war camps in which thousands of them die from malnutrition. That's right. So what are they doing to the black prisoners of war? What they're often doing to the black soldiers, and there are some horrific examples of this, perhaps the most notorious being the Fort Pillow massacre in 1864, when black soldiers surrender, they're just they're being shot and sometimes tortured before they're shot. And the guy who does that Fort Pillow massacre, just to anticipate, he is Nathan
我的意思是，他们把他们关进集中营，让他们挨饿等等。他们把他们关进战俘营，成千上万的人死于营养不良。没错。那么他们是如何对待黑人战俘的呢？他们经常对黑人士兵做的事情，有一些可怕的例子，也许最臭名昭著的是1864年的皮洛堡大屠杀，当黑人士兵投降时，他们只是被枪杀，有时在被枪杀前还会受到折磨。而那个制造皮洛堡大屠杀的人，先预告一下，他就是内森
Bedford Forrest, who's the founder of Ku Klux Klan. That's right, isn't it? Yeah, that's right. Yeah. So is there a continuity between the violence towards black soldiers in the civil war and then the paramilitary violence um after the civil war in the south that basically is one of the explanations for why black americans don't have this new birth of freedom that they think they've been promised yes definitely um you know slavery is uh is inherently a violent system of oppressing an entire race of people. As slavery fractures and comes to an end, other systems of violence come into play. This is evident not just in the South, but in the North, right? Because there are, in 1863, terrible riots in New York prompted by the introduction of a draft there. And that sees black people lynched for, what, three or four days, is it, of rioting in New York? Yes, in July 1863. So, yes, as you say, these are riots by people, and many of them are Irish immigrants, who don't want to be conscripted into the Union Army. But their targets include a coloured orphan asylum, as it's called. In other words,
贝德福德·福雷斯特，他是三K党的创始人。没错，是这样，对吧？是的，没错。是的。那么，内战中对黑人士兵的暴力与内战后南方准军事暴力之间是否存在连续性，这基本上是为什么美国黑人没有得到他们认为被承诺的“自由的新生”的解释之一吗？是的，绝对是。你知道，奴隶制本质上是一种压迫整个种族的暴力制度。随着奴隶制的瓦解和终结，其他暴力系统开始发挥作用。这不仅在南方显而易见，在北方也是如此，对吧？因为在1863年，纽约发生了可怕的骚乱，起因是那里引入了征兵制。这导致黑人在纽约被私刑处死，持续了三四天的骚乱，是吗？是的，在1863年7月。所以，是的，正如你所说，这些是人们发起的骚乱，其中许多是爱尔兰移民，他们不想被征召入联邦军队。但他们的目标包括一个所谓的有色人种孤儿院。换句话说，
visible African-American properties and places and people in New York City are among the main targets of the rioting mob in New York. So there is a rise in anti-black violence across the North in 1863 and 1864. And there's a sense in which that's being driven, as in that instance in New York, by people who believe that they, white people, are being called upon to make sacrifices on behalf of black people. And that somehow the government is now, the Lincoln administration is somehow now privileging black people and demanding sacrifices from poor whites in order to uplift black people. And is that because Lincoln has changed the terms of the war, because of emancipation, do you think? Is that driving that?
纽约市可见的非裔美国人财产、场所和个人是纽约骚乱暴徒的主要目标之一。因此，1863年和1864年，整个北方的反黑人暴力事件有所增加。在某种意义上，正如纽约的那次事件一样，这是由那些认为他们——白人——被要求代表黑人做出牺牲的人所驱动的。而且不知何故，政府现在，林肯政府现在似乎在优待黑人，并要求贫穷的白人做出牺牲以提升黑人的地位。你认为这是因为林肯改变了战争的条件，因为解放，你觉得是这样吗？是这在驱动吗？
Definitely. Yes. I mean, Lincoln would say he hasn't really changed the terms of the war because of emancipation, do you think? Is that driving that? Definitely. Yes. I mean, Lincoln would say he hasn't really changed the terms of the war. It's still a war to save the Union, but it's a war in which the only way to save the Union is to pull out what he would have called, other people did as well, the taproot of the rebellion. And the taproot of the rebellion is slavery. So you destroy slavery in order to save the Union. And when you destroyed slavery, you then have the question of how to integrate what they call the freedmen, formerly enslaved people, into the Republic. And so the things are all interrelated. But certainly the perception was that he had totally changed the basis of the war and that therefore the contract on which they may have initially been willing to fight and die had been broken by the Lincoln administration. But Adam, also conversely, can I just ask you, on that question of how freed slaves are to be integrated into the fabric of the Republic, presumably Americans have this very Roman idea of the citizen soldier, and that in a way to fight is to become a citizen is that something that is kind of
绝对是。是的。我的意思是，林肯会说他并没有真正改变战争的条件，因为解放，你觉得是这样吗？是这在驱动吗？绝对是。是的。我的意思是，林肯会说他并没有真正改变战争的条件。这仍然是一场拯救联邦的战争，但这是一场拯救联邦的唯一途径就是拔掉他所称的——其他人也这么称呼——叛乱的“主根”。而叛乱的主根就是奴隶制。所以你摧毁奴隶制是为了拯救联邦。当你摧毁了奴隶制，你就会面临如何将他们所称的“自由人”，即以前被奴役的人，融入共和国的问题。所以这些事情都是相互关联的。但可以肯定的是，人们认为他完全改变了战争的基础，因此林肯政府打破了他们最初可能愿意为之战斗和牺牲的契约。但是亚当，反过来说，我能问你一个问题吗？关于如何将获得自由的奴隶融入共和国的结构中，大概美国人有这种非常罗马式的“公民士兵”观念，即在某种程度上，战斗就是成为公民，这是某种
underlying the recruitment of of black regiments and so on definitely and so in july 1863 you see this juxtaposition of images so irishmen who are often drawn in cartoons as looking like apes, rioting in order to avoid fighting for their country, for the flag, juxtaposed against African-American troops fighting in South Carolina, Fort Wagner and other places, literally dying for the flag in uniform. And so Republicans, supporters of the Lincoln administration, look at that juxtaposition and say, how are we going to build a stable post-war republic once we suppress this rebellion? Who are going to be loyal citizens of this republic? It's going to be black men, especially those who fought in the Union Army. And that's in terms what Lincoln says
黑人团征募背后的基础吗？绝对是。所以在1863年7月，你看到了这些图像的并置：爱尔兰人，他们在漫画中经常被画成看起来像猿猴，为了避免为国家、为国旗而战而骚乱；与在南卡罗来纳州、皮特瓦格纳堡和其他地方作战的非裔美国人部队并置，他们穿着制服，真正地为国旗而死。因此，共和党人，林肯政府的支持者，看着这种并置，说：一旦我们镇压了这场叛乱，我们将如何建立一个稳定的战后共和国？谁将成为这个共和国的忠诚公民？那将是黑人，特别是那些在联邦军队中作战的人。这就是林肯所说的
in what turns out to be his last public address before he's assassinated, in which he says those black men who fought in our armies should surely be given the vote. That's the way his mind is thinking at that point. And he doesn't add, but I don't think this is at all what Lincoln would think. And rioting Irishmen should have the franchise taken away from them. But certainly there are other Republicans who come to that conclusion. Right. And so this serves as a reminder that while the war is going on, so also electoral politics are carrying on. And there is an election coming up, isn't there, in which Lincoln's future as president is at stake. And the prospect of Lincoln losing the presidency, is that really the Confederacy's last chance? Yes, it is. And does that in turn determine, because of Gone with the Wind, it's incredibly famous, the blaze of destruction launched by General Sherman through Georgia and into the Carolinas?
在他被暗杀前的最后一次公开演讲中，他说那些在我们军队中作战的黑人理应获得投票权。这就是他当时的想法。他没有补充说——但我认为这根本不是林肯会想的——骚乱的爱尔兰人应该被剥夺选举权。但肯定有其他共和党人得出了这个结论。对。所以这提醒我们，当战争进行时，选举政治也在进行。而且有一场即将到来的选举，不是吗？林肯作为总统的未来岌岌可危。林肯失去总统职位的可能性，真的是邦联最后的机会吗？是的，确实是。这反过来又决定了——因为《乱世佳人》，它非常出名——谢尔曼将军穿过佐治亚州进入卡罗来纳州所发起的毁灭性大火吗？
Is he trying to kind of demonstrate that the Confederacy is doomed and thereby ensure that Lincoln will win re-election? Or is that too crude an equation? Atlanta falls at the very beginning of September 1864 and the election is in November, I think, and it falls to Sherman. It's a very big strategic gain for the Union. It's a railroad hub and furthermore, it had been under siege. There'd been a kind of standoff at Atlanta for several weeks. It had been unclear whether Sherman would be able to
他是在试图证明邦联注定要失败，从而确保林肯连任吗？还是说这个等式太粗糙了？亚特兰大在1864年9月初陷落，选举是在11月，我想，它是被谢尔曼攻下的。这对联邦来说是一个非常大的战略收益。它是一个铁路枢纽，而且它一直处于被围困状态。在亚特兰大已经僵持了几个星期。当时还不清楚谢尔曼是否能够
break through. So the fact that he does is a huge impetus behind Lincoln's re-election bid in 1864. The real destruction wrought by Sherman's army is in the early months of 1865, or it's actually after the election. But the beginning of it, the origins of it, which is the fall of the Atlanta Deafening, as you say, Tom sets the stage for Lincoln's victory and kind of takes some of the pressure off him. Because earlier, just a few weeks earlier, in August 1864, Lincoln's own political sources were telling him he was going to lose. I mean, he was pretty sure he was going to lose. That's how it looked. And he's up against his own former general, right?
突破。所以他做到了这一事实是林肯1864年竞选连任背后的巨大推动力。谢尔曼军队造成的真正破坏是在1865年的头几个月，或者实际上是在选举之后。但它的开始，它的起源，也就是亚特兰大的陷落，正如你所说，汤姆，为林肯的胜利奠定了基础，并减轻了他的一些压力。因为早些时候，就在几周前，1864年8月，林肯自己的政治消息来源告诉他他会输。我的意思是，他相当确定他会输。当时看起来就是这样。而且他面对的是他自己以前的将军，对吧？
George McClellan. Yeah. Who's the Democrat candidate and who basically says, enough of the war. It's time to settle. Democrats are internally divided and McClellan kind of squirms around on this because after all, he's a general. But at the end of the day, the democratic platform on which McClellan stands commits them to an armistice with a view to negotiation with the idea, they say, of reunion. Right. Then they haven't come to the let the erring sisters depart in peace point of view. They're not saying that they're still saying we want reunion. Almost all of them are. But they're somehow imagining that it can be done through negotiation rather than through war. And what's their attitude on the emancipation of slaves?
乔治·麦克莱伦。是的。他是民主党候选人，他基本上说，战争够了。是时候解决问题了。民主党内部存在分歧，麦克莱伦对此有些闪烁其词，因为毕竟他是一名将军。但归根结底，麦克莱伦所代表的民主党纲领承诺与南方停战，以期进行谈判，他们说，目的是为了“重聚”。对。那么他们还没有达到“让犯错的姐妹们和平离开”的观点。他们不是那样说的，他们仍然说我们想要重聚。几乎所有人都是这样。但他们不知何故想象可以通过谈判而不是通过战争来实现。他们对解放奴隶的态度是什么？
That it's an appalling betrayal and a distraction, that it's counterproductive. So would they have reversed it? They certainly would have reversed it. If McClellan had won, the one thing we can be sure of is that the emancipation policy would have gone. Just on the issue of slaves i mean the one group you haven't yet talked about are the slaves the people in the confederacy the black men and women almost four million of them um and what has their experience been like adam because they're not being caught up by the confederate armies they're still working on the land but presumably the climate well all, all their lives, they have lived
那是可怕的背叛和干扰，是适得其反的。那么他们会撤销它吗？他们肯定会撤销它。如果麦克莱伦赢了，我们可以确定的一件事是，解放政策将会消失。关于奴隶的问题，我的意思是，你还没有谈到的一个群体是奴隶，邦联中的人，黑人男女，几乎有四百万。亚当，他们的经历是怎样的？因为他们没有被邦联军队征召，他们仍然在土地上工作，但大概气候——好吧，他们一生都生活在
in this climate of oppressive, horrific violence, by and large. And has that intensified during the war? Are their lives much worse? Or have many of them fled? Or do they support the South, some of them? Or are they all for the Union? What's the story? They don't support the confederacy whatever sort of neo-confederates today might like to imagine what's happening essentially is that there is a low-level slave rebellion going on from the moment the war begins in 1861 hundreds of thousands of black people um self-emancipate, take freedom into their own hands. And the focus is often Union armies.
这种压迫性的、可怕的暴力气候中，大体上是这样。这在战争期间加剧了吗？他们的生活变得更糟了吗？还是他们中的许多人逃跑了？或者他们中有些人支持南方？还是他们都支持联邦？故事是怎样的？他们不支持邦联，无论今天的“新邦联主义者”可能想象什么。本质上发生的是，从1861年战争开始的那一刻起，就有一场低水平的奴隶叛乱在进行。成千上万的黑人自我解放，将自由掌握在自己手中。而焦点通常是联邦军队。
And this is what forces, one of the main things that forces emancipation onto the political agenda. So immediately, the very beginning of the war in spring 1861, Union commanders have to decide what to do when hundreds or thousands of people whose legal status in Virginia or wherever they are is as property. What do they do when they essentially seek asylum in Union lines? And some Union commanders in the early stages of the war return them to their masters. Many of them say, and this is a kind of famous sleight of hand by a Union General Benjamin Butler, who calls them contraband of war. So he turns the argument of the South that these people are property against them and says, well,
这就是迫使解放进入政治议程的主要因素之一。所以，战争一开始，1861年春天，联邦指挥官就必须决定当成百上千名在弗吉尼亚或其他地方法律地位为财产的人出现时该怎么办。当他们本质上在联邦防线寻求庇护时，他们该怎么办？在战争初期，一些联邦指挥官将他们送回了主人那里。许多人说——这是联邦将军本杰明·巴特勒的一个著名的“障眼法”——他称他们为“战争违禁品”。所以他利用南方关于这些人是财产的论点来反击他们，并说，好吧，
if I got hold of your horses, or if I got hold of your armaments, I would, of course, confiscate them as contraband of war. So if these people are, as you say, your property, then I'm going to seize them as contraband of war at all and in the same way. And so that term contraband then comes into general usage as a general descriptor of essentially self-emancipated and formerly enslaved people. So the famous plantations, presumably it had required a large amount of manpower to keep the apparatus of oppression in place. But these guys are now going off to fight in the Civil War. So who is stopping the slaves from going to going to north or from any fewer people than before hence hence the much uh you know the higher rate of of enslaved people running away and the
如果我拿到了你们的马，或者如果我拿到了你们的武器，我当然会把它们作为战争违禁品没收。所以如果这些人正如你们所说，是你们的财产，那么我也会以同样的方式把他们作为战争违禁品扣押。因此，“违禁品”这个词后来成为描述本质上自我解放和以前被奴役的人的通用术语。所以著名的种植园，大概需要大量的人力来维持压迫机器的运转。但这些人现在去参加内战了。那么是谁在阻止奴隶去北方，或者比以前更少的人？因此，被奴役者逃跑的比率更高，而且
confederacy they're running away but are they are they attacking the plantations are they kind of burning them down or yes they are in some instances they are in some instances there are instances of violence against enslavers um there are um are the Confederacy, when it introduces conscription, introduces a rule that tries to prevent this by saying that if you have a plantation with more than a certain number of enslaved people, then you're allowed an exemption from conscription. But as the war goes on, that, too, comes under pressure. So it's harder and harder to sustain. So it becomes slavery becomes the big sustain so it becomes the slavery becomes the big achilles heel of the confederacy it's really hard to maintain a system of of oppressive slavery in the first place it's even harder to do it when you're trying to fight a war on your own soil
邦联，他们正在逃跑，但他们是在攻击种植园吗？他们是在烧毁它们吗？或者，是的，在某些情况下他们是这样。在某些情况下，有针对奴隶主的暴力事件。有……邦联在引入征兵制时，引入了一条规则，试图通过规定如果你拥有的种植园有超过一定数量的被奴役者，那么你就可以免除征兵，来防止这种情况。但随着战争的进行，这也受到了压力。所以维持它变得越来越难。所以奴隶制变成了邦联最大的阿喀琉斯之踵。首先维持一个压迫性的奴隶制系统本身就很困难，当你试图在自己的土地上打仗时，这就更难了。
and in the end the situation gets so bad that lee actually suggests to robertson davis that they should arm slaves as the union does in the very dying days of the confederacy when it the writing is is not just on the wall but it's all over their faces and all over the building so this is kind of hitler hitler arming 13 year olds exactly yeah at the very dying days they eventually pass a bill which could have promised emancipation to enslaved people who fight for the confederate army but it never goes into effect what's interesting there adam is that at that point they're actually talking about sacrificing slavery to preserve their sort of sexual identity independence yeah their independence so their national identity is not just a fig leaf for slavery it means something to them and they would give up slavery for it is that
最终情况变得如此糟糕，以至于李实际上向罗伯特·E·李建议，他们应该像联邦那样武装奴隶。在邦联垂死的日子里，当墙上不仅写着字，而且写在他们的脸上和整个建筑上时。所以这有点像希特勒武装13岁的孩子。完全正确。是的，在垂死的日子里，他们最终通过了一项法案，本可以承诺给予为邦联军队作战的被奴役者以解放，但它从未生效。亚当，有趣的是，在那个时候，他们实际上是在谈论牺牲奴隶制来维护他们那种某种性别的身份独立。是的，他们的独立。所以他们的民族认同不仅仅是奴隶制的遮羞布，它对他们意味着什么，他们会为了它放弃奴隶制，是这样吗？
that can't be yeah but but but if it had really been um a fight for national self-determination in this gladstonian romantic way then they surely would have made come to that position a good deal yeah so last yeah so could we come to the to that end so lincoln wins election and that really is the kind of the final nail in the coffin what is the end game the end game is that lee's army has eventually um forced to surrender at appomattox courthouse in southwest virginia and uh that is taken although there are still confederate armies in the field because lee's army has been so associated with the confederacy and the figure of Lee himself is so associated with the Confederacy. He personifies the Confederacy far more than Jefferson Davis, the president, does.
那不可能。是的，但是如果这真的是一场为了民族自决的斗争，以这种格莱斯顿式的浪漫方式，那么他们肯定会早得多地达到那个立场。是的。所以，最后，我们能谈谈那个结局吗？林肯赢得了选举，这真的是棺材上的最后一颗钉子。结局是什么？结局是李的军队最终被迫在弗吉尼亚西南部的阿波马托克斯法院投降。虽然战场上还有邦联军队，但这被视为结束，因为李的军队与邦联联系得太紧密了，李本人与邦联的形象联系得太紧密了。他比总统杰斐逊·戴维斯更能体现邦联。
That when Lee surrenders, that is regarded by virtually everybody as the end of the war. And just one quick question about that surrender. Because that surrender moment is very important. Appomattox Courthouse. We talked before about the Roundhead Cavalier thing.ier thing ulysses s grant who we haven't really talked about very much actually yeah so just give us a brief sketch of ulysses s grant dominic i know you're a big fan of his um me yeah you've been going on about him i don't go on about ulysses s grant i know very little about him he's a sort of failure of a man isn't he uh adam he's a drunk
当李投降时，这被几乎所有人视为战争的结束。关于那次投降，还有一个简短的问题。因为那个投降时刻非常重要。阿波马托克斯法院。我们之前谈到了“圆颅党”和“骑士党”的事情。尤利西斯·S·格兰特，我们实际上还没有怎么谈论过他。是的，所以给我们简要介绍一下尤利西斯·S·格兰特，多米尼克，我知道你是他的大粉丝。我吗？你一直在谈论他。我没有谈论尤利西斯·S·格兰特，我对他的了解很少。他是个失败的人，不是吗？亚当，他是个酒鬼，
who is sort of transformed by the war. He's Jared Harris in the film. He's transformed by the war, and he becomes Lincoln's indispensable general. And the reason that he lingers in the memory, I mean, he tarnishes his own reputation because he becomes a sort of slightly shop-sored president later on, doesn't he? He's gilded age and corrupt and all that kind of stuff.
被战争改变了。他是电影里的杰瑞德·哈里斯。他被战争改变了，成为了林肯不可或缺的将军。他之所以留在记忆中——我的意思是，他玷污了自己的名声，因为他后来变成了一个稍微有点名声扫地的总统，不是吗？他是镀金时代，腐败等等。
I think he gets a bit of a bad rap actually very um dan jackson friend of the show very keen on him because he goes to newcastle and sunderland yeah he does in his in his global tour yes but anyway sorry we're the contrast between him and lee he's a sort of round-headed shabby figure and he takes the surrender of Lee who's got dressed up you know especially for it hasn't he uh but Grant allows Lee and his men to leave with honor and they and they don't they get to keep their horses and they get to go off and he gives them rations now there are two ways of talking about that moment I mean we'll get into the the legacy of the war in the next episode but one is to say oh isn't that lovely they're all friends again and the union
我认为他实际上受到了不公正的评价。非常……丹·杰克逊，节目的朋友，非常喜欢他，因为他去了纽卡斯尔和桑德兰。是的，他在他的全球巡演中确实去了。但无论如何，抱歉，我们谈谈他和李之间的对比。他是一个圆颅党式的、衣着寒酸的人物，他接受了李的投降，李可是特意打扮了一番，不是吗？但格兰特允许李和他的部下带着荣誉离开，他们可以保留他们的马，他们可以离开，他还给了他们口粮。现在，有两种谈论那个时刻的方式。我的意思是，我们将在下一集中讨论战争的遗产，但一种说法是，哦，那不是很可爱吗？他们又成了朋友，联邦
is remade and all that sort of thing but adam could you say and i would say that creates huge problems for the future because what it does is it almost recognize instead of treating the confederates as rebels and as traitors it recognizes them as worthy noble opponents and in that moment at appomattox courthouse you have the creation of this myth that what the thing we've talked about so much the cavalier idea oh the confederates were great noble fellows and it's such a shame they fell out do you not think that's there right at the beginning at appomattox courthouse i think i think we should save this for the next episode because it's so crucial. Shocking. You've set it up and it is
被重塑了等等。但亚当，你能说——我会说这为未来制造了巨大的问题，因为它所做的是，它几乎承认了——而不是把邦联视为叛军和叛徒——它承认他们是值得尊敬的、高尚的对手。在阿波马托克斯法院的那一刻，你创造了这个神话，即我们谈论了那么多的“骑士”观念：哦，邦联是伟大高尚的家伙，他们失败了真是太可惜了。你不认为这在阿波马托克斯法院一开始就存在吗？我想，我想我们应该把这个问题留到下一集，因为它太关键了。令人震惊。你已经铺垫好了，而且它是
absolutely clearly the key question is how the war is going to be seen. I am going to let Adam answer the question but I'm going to save it for the next episode where we will look at the events that immediately follow Lee's surrender of which
绝对清楚的关键问题是战争将如何被看待。我将让亚当回答这个问题，但我会把它留到下一集，届时我们将看看李投降后立即发生的事件，其中
one obviously no spoilers is particularly significant and then we will look at how the civil war has been understood and how it has influenced the actual course of politics and society in america well ever since what what tom has done very beautifully once again is to allow us an opportunity to say that if you can't wait for adam's answer you merely need to go to restishistorypod.com and sign up to the rest is history club and within seconds you will hear adam answering that question the rest of you however will have to wait a little longer and we will see you next time goodbye bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
一个显然——没有剧透——特别重要，然后我们将看看内战是如何被理解的，以及它如何影响了美国政治和社会的发展，嗯，从那时起。汤姆再次非常漂亮地做了一件事，那就是让我们有机会说，如果你等不及亚当的回答，你只需要去restishistorypod.com并注册加入“历史就是历史”俱乐部，几秒钟内你就会听到亚当回答那个问题。然而，你们其他人将不得不等待更长的时间，我们下次见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史就是历史》。如需额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。